the squat Democrats are agitating again
over Israel the radical lawmakers had a
big week of calling for ceasefires and
spreading Hamas propaganda that blamed
the Jewish State for the Gaza Hospital
explosion today they were backing back
at a backing Hamas on the National Mall
and bashing Joe
Biden calling on Congress for more bombs
and more
weapons which we know will only lead to
more violence and more death and more
atrocity and absolutely
not absolutely not most America is not
with you Mr
President most of America is not with
the people that don't want to deescalate
and facilitate a ceasefire but you're
obviously not talking to these Americans
how many more killings is enough for you
is it a thousand more 2,000 more 3,000
more how many more Palestinians would
make you happy if they
died elhan Omar getting grilled by
Hillary vau over why she's been calling
for a ceasefire between Israel and Hamas
you call for a ceasefire are you okay
with Hamas terrorists continuing to
exist do you think that Israel should
just lay down their arms and not try to
get the hostages out of
God how can Israel have a ceasefire with
terrorists whose entire mission is to
out El please you're blocking an
elevator she's got how can they have a
seeg fire if they're trying to wipe out
crazy lady don't worry
about so uh Jessica the old saying is
that Israel ceases and whatever
terrorist group of the day just keeps
firing uh you see that Hamas has not
stopped firing Rockets we now have them
coming in from the north uh from Lebanon
into Israel so they're calling for a
ceasefire when the people who started
this whole thing aren't even putting
their arms down right it was a very
quick moment of silence on their behalf
for the massacre and then within 24
hours or so it was moved to this and
like I just said if you're not leading
your argument or whatever however you
were speaking about this with who
committed this atrocity who started this
this isn't about litigating settlements
in the West Bank or going back to 1967
lines it's terrorism
and it's really interesting to see so
this um ceasefire proposal out of
Congress had 13 signatories and then you
look to the leaders of these movements
Elizabeth Warren right Bernie Sanders
people very far in the Progressive left
who are not touching it with a 10- foot
pole they want to make sure that
humanitarian Aid gets into Gaza and a
lot of more mainstream Democrats believe
in that as well they're not calling for
a ceasefire no one showed up on
September 12th and told us why don't you
guys all get back in bed right we don't
have to talk about what happens next
there are good people on both sides of
it blah blah blah it's infuriating I'm
not Democratic Leadership honestly I
don't think it's about some sort of
dereliction of Duty when they say I
don't want to talk about I think they're
just annoyed and like this is such a
sideshow from what's going on Biden
speaks for us this
is not worth our time so Jesse you can
argue that a series of ceasefires over
the past two decades have led to what
happened on o October 7th this idea that
you can do a ceasefire which is not a
treaty or a peace agreement and you can
just manage this terrorist group that
says they want to kill all the Jews on
the planet but really they don't mean it
that much yeah ceasefire is not an
effective Terror strategy and it might
sound good to the pnik wing or the
anti-semitic Wing but you can't win the
war on te with ceasefires and they know
that they're just appealing to The
Fringe and and they took direct threats
at their president they said that
they're not going to vote for the top of
the ticket they named swing States they
Nam Pennsylvania they Nam Georgia they
named Michigan you say it's a sow this
is a loud sow and this sesow could have
legs Jessica these are people that are
appealing to a younger demographic that
have been brought out of the woodwork
you've seen the crowds these are not
small Gatherings this was not a small
gathering the ones Johnny's at is
gathering downtown right now you're
underestimating the visceral hatred that
they're tapping into here and Omar seems
angry at Jewish people more than she's
angry at Hamas and they have to
understand that Hamas brought the
suffering upon the Palestinian people
the Jewish people did not so this is
going to be a big problem for Joe Biden
electorally and it's going to be a big
problem for the Democrats in terms of
their brand so great I think we need
some a d of Joan Rivers's response to
this type of thing when they call for a
ceasefire they started it it's sad
because you know Omar what happened to
loving your brother you
know at this point why are we covering
them I will go I Jessica is partly right
in that they hold no sway over the party
but they do hold sway over us you know
because they're interesting they you
know they they drive your emotions but I
think you know why are we giving these
wrongheaded nutcakes the oxygen let them
fill in the hours at MSNBC the squad is
now their only viewers and soon to be
hosts in fact if I were MSNBC I would
hire I think there are five now right I
think there are five in the squad
there's one dude they're perfect call it
the squad have it at 5:00 pm and the
motto is it's the five without brains
because it's another problem with this
moment by- moment coverage is having a
comment on the vomit that comes out of
their mouths maybe we pull back from
these chuckleheads too we got enough
hate bubbling up from Hamas in the
streets filled with sympathizers these
freaks have bounced themselves from
normal conversation they don't deserve
our time as you said but we do to your
point Jesse uh we do we do do need to
look at our culture we need to step back
and realize that this isn't really about
their influence on the party it's about
their influence on a younger generation
who have lost the ability to love this
country maybe never did Jessica GRE said
you right twice the show so I just want
my mom actually had a heart
attack Life Alert on I'll let you know
if there're anymore um judge just to go
back to the smear that the squad has
continued to perpetuate that the
Israelis targeted deliberately a
hospital in Gaza when it was one of
their own Rockets from Islamic Jihad
Hamas is firing Rockets every single day
at hospitals in Israel and nobody's
freaking out about that being a war
crime you know the the thing about this
uh that is very disturbing and should be
disturbing to everyone who's got at
least half a brain is that it is already
the idea that Israel uh flew the the the
rocket or the missile into that hospital
has been debunked I mean we've got
visual we've got audio we've got
Communications between Hamas leaders uh
it clearly was not Israel and the squad
calling for a
ceasefire um and continually railing
against Israel to me makes them
complicit with Hamas
Israel has the right to defend herself
Israel was attacked children went to
sleep in their own beds to become
victims of unspeakable torture and abuse
and violence and and Massacre it was
Palestine who voted Hamas into power in
2007 when Israel said we're done you can
have Gaza and they voted for Hamas and
Hamas Charter is to Massacre all the
Jews all right let's stop playing
playing you know foot around here
they can talk about anything they want
how many more do you want to die well
maybe you ought to start with the fact
that the Israelis were living uh a
peaceful existence there allowing 20,000
Palestinians to come through their
border every day to work and make a
living and go back to Gaza that the
Israelis are the one who were providing
water and electricity when Gaza could
have been as they said the Singapore of
the of the Middle East on the
Mediterranean
but Hamas prevented it and as the
Western World now Bloomberg too is like
oh Israel you know be careful slow down
hogwash they lost lives they've got
hostages Israel knows what they're doing
let them fight they have a right to
fight they have a right to defend
themselves and as my friend says it's
not 67 it's not 73 this is everything to
do with the existence of Israel as a
nation state indeed hey Sean here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else